live hey everybody welcome to stream
coco
yeah
beth morosky in the house jason o'malley
creeper in the corner he's so far is he
gonna make it over here on camera is he
gonna make it over here on camera he's
gonna make it over here on camera he's
gonna make it over here on camera he's
gonna make it there he is welcome
everyone glad you could join us today
we're playing one of my very favorite
games it's a steam game called super hot
uh it's bananas sorry for the crazy uh
this crazy uh annoying thing there
access denied uh oh
oh oh enter authorized password
press a to send here we go let's get
into it oh this is part of the game
access granted yeah this game is kind of
a little bit of a it's a meta game the
idea is your friend has sent you a cool
new game called super hot no one knows
what it's about
and uh you're gonna we're gonna play it
it's awesome uh
good hello in finland hello yo men
what's up good to see you uh i'm not
super hot uh captain quasar thank you
i'm super gross but uh whatever morbid
uh 6253 i just saw conan in the hallway
i don't know if he'll be in today or not
we'll see um yes thank you i guess
lizzie i'm super hot that's not true uh
george schleske is currently in his
office we will email him to see if he
wants to come in last time you guys let
us down and he didn't come in uh but uh
like every uh uh stream coco we might
have some celebrity guests today we
might not
probably not but you never know
that's right you got a virus says fox
delta so this game
is extremely exciting
now this game oh i'd love to turn this
volume up the idea behind super hot and
this is why i love it is it's kind of a
first person puzzler
so in this game
when you move
that's when
time moves when you
oh oh we lost everything oh we're back
oh that's part of the game okay
part of the game
they cracked the system uh oh
what oh oh you know what we're actually
starting
where i played at my house okay so see
as you move you can see the bullets oh
[ __ ]
that's cool and you're trying to kill
guys oh i totally don't remember we set
up the gyroscope for aiming
uh yeah we used uh so we're using a
steam controller today there it is right
there pretty awesome uh i highly
recommend this steam controller it's
pretty dope it's got a bunch of crazy
buttons on it it's got two track pads
there you go boom i also give you the
devil horns there you are and then it's
got your your typical buttons here your
bumpers your triggers but it's also got
these little buttons on the back which
are fun
and you can program all this stuff
depending on how you want so this is
kind of a track pad
here and then you can go on when you go
on the steam community you can download
different controller configurations and
people have kind of made their own
oh this is not going to go well for me
did i dodge it i did
the thing is can i get to this guy and
beat him up
you missed me
can you not see that there we go boom
let's grab that gun
killed him what are they made out of
they're made out of plastic parts we're
getting hit by this bullet
we got killed all right
super hot
we're starting over it's like i said
it's kind of a puzzler so you got to
kind of as you go through the game you
got to figure it out hey darling d ooh
darling dries
dee streaming live from africa oh man
wow awesome that's great
lumification conan smells like nervous
cheese i would say
is what he smells like what is what is
the most nervous cheese
the most nervous cheese i think is
probably
uh
well i'd say brie maybe because it's
kind of soft and it also like it has
like a coat on all the time because it's
like yeah exactly
okay here let's see if we can get to
this guy over here
he's going to shoot at us someone should
do a super cut of aaron's deaths per
season of monday melee yeah let's uh i
would just you just watch all the monday
maybe
let's keep let's keep track of the let's
keep track of the deaths oh there you
see this guy's who killed us before
so we're just going to kill this dude
boom dead
provolone is the most nervous people say
is there a dude
where do i go now i think i'm gonna
sneak this let this guy come around the
corner
let him come around the corner at us
right
pop him
oh i gotta reload [ __ ]
got him
dead
all right well now where's our boy up
here oh there's a guy right over there
let's go this way
does anyone else think this guy looks
like bruce willis do you get a lot of oh
magazine empty let's throw our gun at
him
i thought it was bruce willis i wonder
if i can oh there we go oh now you're in
trouble
this guy is dead
oh
i'm not the only one who can dodge
bullets apparently
kill them
oh
whoops oh come on oh there's a fourth
dude damn it
i think i need to do a little
controlling of my er chain oh no what
happened
uh whoops i need to do a little how do i
on my controller options here
no no no
drug configuration let's get down i i
the thing is i want to um
let's see where's i don't want to add
action set i want to make it so it's
less crazy
i need to make the mouse less crazy here
we go sensitivity let's bring that down
bring that down a bit friend
let's bring it down to about there i
think it's good
sorry guys you know when you're as good
a player as i am
you got to make sure your [ __ ] is set up
uh i'm a pretentious dick all right here
we go let's get back into it you rock
man hey roberto you rock thank you
um all right here oh way better wait
sorry it does that all right way better
here we go let's get into it they
cracked the system
this guy's going to come at us missed me
i'll take that
see you later oh
crotch shot boom
i know crotchery this guy's firing at me
you can
oh boy
boom dead
got him oh let's just slide by these
bullets shall we
who miss me
we'll just pop this guy while we're over
here
oh no ammo damn it all right you should
try tilting your controller around to
aim does the controller still
oh damn it we hit him in the face though
oh can i do this let's try that i don't
know if i've got that contribution
super hot uh strontium dog i don't know
if i could duck that's a good question
hold a restart nope
does it this doesn't matter nothing
don't touch no don't even try i love
this game
no i can't duck and i can't
no the controller i mean i could make it
so the controller i could aim by that's
going to screw me up
all right here we go i think we go
if we go to the left we're getting
screwed so let let's pop this guy
can i punch him yet
and
punch i'll take
that thank you
let's shoot this dude who's coming at us
then let's kill this guy
oh one punch i go down
lame
the five deeds of dodgeball dodge duck
dip dive and dodge you said dodge twice
that's four ds
is conan still in korea no he's been
banned what's up yeah conan is
definitely not in korea although
mentally probably still mentally he's
never gonna leave emotionally he's never
gonna leave i will say it's gonna be
hard
wherever we go next our next travel show
going to be hard
guys whatever country you go to if we
visit your country you better bring it
because uh conan that's going to be
tough to be at least 2001 people at the
airport yeah and
dead
hey folks hey ruda what's up
i suck thanks hope rosa by the way if
your name
is or maybe it's hoppa
all right whatever one punch gladreal i
know
what are we at six deaths
they crack the code they crack the
system here we go
we're gonna hit this guy in the face
come to the netherlands send us snacks
yeah send us snacks dude
i'll take this could i just pick this
gun up please
nailed it
kill this guy
dead
now let's back it up
what are you doing oh he's running for
that gun
i got a gun for you
right in the crotch boom dead
all right now it gets tricky because we
don't have any more ammo
so let's pop by here
let this guy come at us
somebody else is shooting at me which is
very bad
you know where the bullets are coming
from it's a bad scene man
how do you feel about that
let's throw it at him
got him oh
that guy's going to fire at us though
that's dope
oh a little cat and mouse eh in the old
stacks
when in doubt back it up back it up
let them come after us you know
no thanks
f this dude by the way
did we get them all
i
see you
is that it
no because the level's not over
there's another dude in here where is he
at
oh i see you
gotcha pal magazine empty nope dead
hot
super see now it shows it to you in in
uh real time which is dope
here we go let's do it let's do it get
him
and boom pow
boo
right in the dick
i took my time with that one oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah get him get him you can
also the cool thing about super hot is
you can upload your best uh moves to
killstagram.com oh man is that your
favorite if you're
killstagram.com right i don't want to
edit the replay
i just want to keep playing
do we just do i just hit a
hit x
i just want to i would like to continue
playing
i just want to keep playing how do i do
it how do i do it
uh
you win says i thought i was gonna see
conor not the guy from orange county
choppers
what
i look like the guy from orange county
choppers really who is the guy from
orange county
how do i play the next level
oh i don't want to replay this level
this guy
[ __ ] wait we just did this i don't
replay this dumb level
how do we get out of here
i think they're saying this is you
i'm this guy
wait this is the dude you think i look
like
[Laughter]
no
really i think i can't tell the
difference [ __ ] off why are you holding
up a photo of yourself okay
incoming message here we go
see this is the meta game on top of this
i want to play i want to play a stupid
password
something weird happened i think i just
saw myself in the game it didn't look
like my room but somehow i knew it was
like in a dream
what i got in whoa wait a second that's
not what we typed
whoa dude something's in the matrix
agent smith
by the way i read a cool thing about the
matrix the other day that said agent
smith was actually the one
oh
hey neo cause neo was spoilers by the
way for a movie that came out in 1999
look at this sounds like you're playing
too much this is not what i'm typing
i mean i'm not typing anything i'm just
going like this
see look at this look that's just what i
say and then it's going to change it to
something who are we communicating with
our friend
see
because agent smith was the rogue piece
and the reason why the robots made peace
with the humans is because agent smith
had gotten into the humans which means
that agent smith could get to the
architect because the architect was
outside the matrix meaning agent smith
could take over the world
so that's why they decided to work with
the humans
isn't that crazy oh look at this oh look
oh here it goes
i was more cool when i was fatter like
jonah hill
thank you for comparing me to jonah hill
yeah he's a successful actor i uh years
ago was at a new year's eve party at
jonah hill when he was fatter when both
of us were fatter the tutorial
this is what you think you need
wait for the signal
hi coffee
[Music]
wait for the signal yo
we're waiting for it
[Music]
i'm moving bro
[Music]
this is dope by the way i love this
that was
it it says press a to hand over the
control but i can't
[Music]
crazy
good dog
make him fly all right
haha there he goes bye
let's go
let's shoot this dude
oh brother
oh i can jump
whoa i can jump well
and i'm
dead
saying that you haven't bound anything
to a so it won't do anything oh yeah
so that's why i got to use the trigger
thanks y'all
i could probably shoot this guy from
here i think
how do i throw again
[Music]
oh he shot my gun out of the air
uh is that gonna hit us no
wait why can't we duck
i don't know
exactly
it's possible we might be able to
is there a gun somewhere
in the walls
i gotta get over there
oh there's experiments oh that's a bad
bullet
i think i gotta get a gun to kill this
guy
so let's go get a gun
am i going to get it by the time i get
shot
one's all it takes
boom
dead that guy is dead happening in this
area i don't know exactly
oh what
oh i missed him
oh this is very bad what's about to
happen i can punch this dude
uh
can i punch you yet
take that
oh [ __ ]
i like to shoot him in the dick whenever
possible
just how i do you know
oh god
let's kill that dude
there are a lot of guys over here
oh [ __ ] dude so many guys
this is like a german existential
nightmare something cunha would think of
that's true
hey there's a weird echo from coming
over there a
it's just my headphones mouse
oh perfect
it seems pretty synced though yeah it
does seem sick all right bye bye all
right let's do it
let's kill this dude
i think i gotta again i think i gotta
back up
i have the flu so i can actually watch
this
perfect
pistol has four bullets got it
oh we just hit 4 million subscribers on
youtube hey
there we go yay
thanks gang
thank you guys
hello to our four million oh i'm dead
all four million of you are watching
right now too oh wait 560.
hi joseph person
no guns over here oh wait what's this
oh damn it
dude i died i've died three more times
than that one thousand viewer hi
what's up 1k viewers
if you want to use the motion controls
to aim you have to reset your thumb the
track pad to enable it oh i don't know
if it's going to be good for me to do
that i don't i don't feel like that's a
good i feel like i'm better with the
track pad no
i'll take that gun i do love in this
game if you guys are just joining us
we're playing super hot on steam today
which is an awesome indie game
super fun i do one of my things is i
love
when they're when i see new things in
video games and this is
something definitely new
i'm gonna whip my gun over there
oh man i hit the wrong button ah damn it
[ __ ]
put you guys over the four million mark
now give me a lock of conan's hair what
are you talking about weapon x
oh got him
god they do the assault rifle knocked
him down oh give it to me give it to me
thank you
[Music]
got him
here comes a guy out of that oh what
you did [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] all right guys we
gotta get past this level this is making
me crazy
all right here we go
guy doesn't even know it's about to hit
him give it to me hey can you put the
chat over the other uh window there
mouse thanks pal
i only noticed because twitch had your
stream featured on the front page oh
thank you to twitch for hooking us up
with front page love thanks twitch
thanks twitch
i missed him seems impossible
but i will take that gun
and end your life with it
walk between the raindrops baby it's fun
to watch conan because he's bad at video
games
that is the point
yep
thanks for watching i hope you guys
liked uh the last close gamer we did
with seth rogen zac efron
i'm gonna kill the [ __ ] out of this guy
right now
uh where we play mario kart and they
oh i missed him oh no i hit him
and they drew penises all over uh his
face
[Music]
oh that guy has got to die
oh
man
what's that what's anybody have any
advice here
guys i need your help to beat this level
please write your advice in the chat
so we don't have to play this level 50
more times because i'm terrible at games
and then your advice for blade and not
die send in your advice for me to not
die
i love seth oh yeah i know he seth they
were so nice by the way
uh and it was hilarious them drawing
dicks on conan's face and we actually
had a real
well we gotta ask matt by the way about
that video but we actually have i think
it's yeah i think there's gonna be a
thing
extra bit yeah i do think there's gonna
be an extra bit at some point yeah yeah
because we actually had to have a long
conversation about what
what kind of dicks could be drawn
because zach drew a dick in the very
beginning
that was dribbling down conan's nose and
that was like one of the big no-nos so
we were trying to figure out what's the
best way to get around the fact that
zach drew a drippy dick
someone said wonder if you could run
behind run past all these guys and kill
them from behind
not a bad idea use of each bullet use
cover and let them come to you
not a bad idea class will stop the first
bullet if it breaks
play slower and methodical i'm trying
smart about it
i'm trying
do it smart
oh we
ducked
i gotta get rid of that guy first i
think
damn it
all right oh hey everybody it's rj
feeneyman what welcome rj hi hey
what's up man oh thanks man i've been
looking for these yeah buddy dope here
once you sit in the middle here pal okay
say hi to everybody in the chat
oh
hey chat i've been here in a while this
is a nice setup oh yeah man you're going
on what all right we're playing this
game called super hot is this a real
game it no it's not a real game yeah
well yes we're playing it what do you
mean you make this game it's a real game
yeah even if beth what you're saying
beth can't make real games thank you is
that what you're saying beth can't make
real games she can make real games how
do you pl uh it looks super exciting it
is really awesome actually is it what is
uh shooting it's it's the idea is
i'm gonna grab this gun hey guys say hi
to some folks in the chat hey guys
people are happy today rj it's paul rudd
he doesn't love that
i'm right instead of rj you know
you're okay
so you just kill people in slow motion
oh yeah all right here it goes so here's
the deal yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah time
moves when you move
when you're not moving time doesn't move
it's still oh yeah okay okay okay all
right so here's how you play so you move
around with this right this is your aim
wait see like this i know it's a steam
controller what this is your shoot
or like action button so here we can
punch that guy so if you hit this
trigger you'll punch him wait isn't that
the same button oh no
and then when you move close see when
you see this then you can grab that
thing
and left trigger throws your gun like
when you're out of bullets you just whip
it at somebody it's dope so this guy's
already dead it only takes one shot to
kill people
i've never used this controller
it's just like imagine this is another
stick
okay okay
yeah move around that's right uh oh eric
all right eric burrows great advice
shoot sooner and lead my bullets this is
very good slow how do i oh
i
still i'm sorry everyone this is going
to be awful difficult for me when you
move camera
oh oh the camera yeah when you move the
camera it goes slow
this is brilliant glad you guys are on
twitch thank you amicon
pekko22
i'm not gonna lie i don't know what
the [ __ ] to do right now oh can i go
through this jump out the window yeah so
you want to go that way you want to kill
that guy down there
all right lol ig world says all right
live streaming game so you press this
and that and this and that and this and
that's simple
really all there is team controller is
awful i don't know i like nice things
steam controller is pretty good it's all
about the configuration you get so and
you won't be able to shoot again until
the
until the recticle goes like this
so see the butt okay see the the axe
when it's up and you'll hear a click
you might want to move back he's going
to shoot at you
oh
there you go now see it since it's up
and down you can shoot him
oh it's nice well done oh and then grab
that gun down there because yeah then
you can get more [ __ ] can i die will
i die if i fall down no no definitely
not all right all right go for it
recticle oh go nude that's probably for
seriously raven dark 667 this will end
him playing gears of war again
jump off and see how far did you get
says
how do i pick this up yay coffee man sam
no no no you gotta look at it okay
you gotta get closer and then when you
get close enough it'll turn to a hand
this is the hardest game i've ever
played
why isn't it doing it i don't know
i need like a
a tutorial on how to use that right
that's so weird
you do it yeah it looks like i know why
it's not working it looks like so oh
[ __ ] oh here comes a guy
shooting that as we'll throw our gun
whoa
does that kill him yeah dude oh no it
just stuns him but then
that'll kill him
all right here we go wait i'm like
watching you do this i don't know all
right so
it's simple this
trackpad is just like a second
stick see how i'm moving with my thumb
kind of and you can that's why did i
throw my thing at him that was dumb you
know what i'm saying
so this is you just move this around
it's just like a stick yeah
you know see
see what i'm saying but it's like
it it's like what
it's like what i don't know it doesn't
like the stick you have to hold this one
you have to like you push it around
you know what i'm saying
yeah it's like a track pad you mean
exactly like i just said yeah i don't
know what a track pad is what the this
is a trackpad kidding me i've never used
a trackpad what yeah you have you have a
laptop what are you even talking about
now i have one of the older ones with a
little ball don't have i've seen your
[ __ ] thing you're being stupid okay
now i know what a trackpad is oh my god
you didn't know what a trackpad was no
didn't know it was called a trackpad i
missed that dude
damn it don't judge me o'malley yeah
o'malley is judging the [ __ ] out of you
you deserve to be look at them judy
who's that guy on the table is there a
story to this or we just yeah there is
kind of a meta story
meta story i'm gonna kill this dude who
comes out of here like do they know
you're in a video game yeah that's kind
of over the thing oh god damn this guy
oh here comes a guy out of here let's
pop him
here he comes what hey buddy
dead
oh interesting it works more like a
trackball than a trackpad if you flick
it it'll continue spinning
yeah it's like there is like a trackball
internally in there
so rj all your time with your packball
perfect
all right hold on i just gotta kill this
dude real quick
whoa
did you get them both in one bullet no
did i i think so twofer
hold on i'm doing really good just give
me a sec you aim so well
video games bro
that was cool
what buttons you pressed to pick that up
i guess it doesn't matter because time
stops so i can ask yeah
oh [ __ ] so many guns to pick up you guys
oh they're both going for the same gun
that's awkward
dead fran bren why isn't the girl
playing
first of all the girl's name is
i don't have a name
it's okay
hot super now we see now we see
everything we did in real time boom
watch this here we go and oh [ __ ] boo
take it
take it take it
through that guy take this gun
uh the guy didn't appear we shot that
dude
there he comes boom right in the face oh
pow got him oh double hit that was
awesome by the way the double hit was
dope
can i why is it called super hot is
there a reason cause it's super hot dude
all right all right you're up next okay
oh
what
whoa
inside job dude what all right grab a
bottle grab a bottle yeah there you go
dry trigger
throw it at the guy throw it at the guy
i mean i guess i don't you don't need to
do it quickly the whole point of the
game is you don't do it quickly line it
up line it up throw it boom
get the thing get the punch him to death
[ __ ] really beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah
guys super hot kappa sorry that's true
remnant haru
beth is a million times better than rj
true this is rj theater rj explain what
you do hey i work for
so when that stuff blows up they're dead
go okay okay okay uh konico is conan's
production company so that's right all
the shows that are not the late night
talk show can i pick up another bottle
or should i pick up as many as you want
but i would get a gun at some point or
you could you know get on your behind
you behind you grab that yeah oh yeah
time to beat somebody to death let's get
him let's get out there baby you can
also i would yeah that guy's going we'll
whip it out oh my god that was crazy
jesus go slow dude throw it at him left
trigger
left trigger left trigger oh my god no
no no no no no no no
oh why can't i oh it's coming at you
oh it broke slow move slow i would i
would like move up that way
kind of towards him but to the side
there we go you got oh my god you don't
have a weapon i don't have a weapon you
can go down and grab something
oh dead got killed go again jesus says
the unicorn your kitchen sorry
i'm sorry endermore nice indie games are
my thing they're our thing too i love
indie games is this an indie game why do
these jello men want you dead to the gym
that's a good question so this game's
super hot we're playing today basically
the idea is the idea behind it is
your friend has sent you a game called
super hot and this is when you play it
you go into this kind of tron-esque
world okay and then i would whip it at
that how do you throw it again uh left
trigger
oh but you gotta wait for that guy to
get out of the way i'll throw a bottle
at that guy and so you start playing
this game and then the game becomes
self-aware and knows that you're playing
it whoa so i uh my theory is that this
might not be an actual game you might be
killing these guys for real oh super
high or something yeah the game is super
hot can i punch this guy or is he going
to kill sifra asks rj do you like
websites
uh some websites okay like weather
websites if your friends
neo wolf if your friend sent me this
game i would get a new friend exactly
super hot okay there's no head
let's do this
oh yeah now follow see but then if you
followed up you can grab the gun out of
the air is this guy really dead no when
they explode they die hit one more time
there you go oh
supa is swedish for boozing i need this
gun
why can't i get it there you got it oh
they can punch you to death to shoot him
nice so you're right dude be careful i
think there's probably a guy there nope
maybe i'm wrong
there's a bottle there's a bottle all
right there's got to be other guys
because the game's not over here
i'm getting a hang of it you know
is there a guy behind me eric eric's
eric morenz is laughing at something you
guys should play some retro games says
technic well we might end with gears of
war today we've been doing that lately
that's just how we end it's just how we
go out here no you can't go through
there aim for the head
wait for the head aim for the head
there's somebody i would go slow i feel
like try walking around to the left
there's somebody over there
i like the rain you would tell your
friend hey good job but try not to make
them so
jello willy
i think he might use that
sorry i guess we could do the gyro to
aim we could try doing that
configuration
[Music]
sun
i don't know oh there's a guy oh here he
comes here he comes
oh
pop him
right in the back you can't see it but
the creeper is creepy dick shot oh you
missed him you missed him he's true
creeping oh no you hit him well done
what are you doing what are you [ __ ]
what are you creeping about he's creepy
a creeper why is he creeping
that's cicero i'm hosting a retro show
tonight at seven
oh
damn son got killed right when i was
getting the gun got killed you got this
are we excited about the battlefield 5
announcement oh
i like battlefield
wow don't need to aim for the head a
shot to torso will kill or chateau the
dude
you're going to be an uncharted 4
clueless gamer i don't know maybe i got
to play the other uncharted games i hear
they're awesome
oh he's so sad
get in there oh you're oh
punch him punch him punch him
yeah grab the thing dude grab the thing
there's a guy to your left ah
gotta move out of the way man yeah here
comes that bullet the bullet's coming
dude oh i see you give a [ __ ]
it's coming man you gotta get out of the
way guys i'm not good at this game
holy crap battlefield five play the
entire game of legends of zelda
link to the past i haven't played that
one ocarina of time
that's one of my favorite games of all
time yeah oh yeah
is conan going to e3
i don't know
are you going to e3 i don't know
uh yeah i'll be going
beth will be there
beth how was your weekend
it was great
i got killed i drink watermelon oh the
guy picked up the thing i didn't kill
him you did what do you drink what i
drink all the mimosas
in the valley they're out
conor should play overwatch in the next
clueless gamer yeah that'd be dope
what's that game that's awesome that's
like a uh that's like a
game where people in the face sorry oh
yeah gbs i was listening to the song of
storm such a great soundtrack agreed
ocarina of time for life
i don't even wait to see if they die do
you have this game at home yeah it's
awesome
actually because we started kind of
halfway through because i've been
playing it a lot have you beat it uh no
is that just a thing still people like
beating games
you know what i mean
no like there's all these no people stop
trying to play games no because it's not
cool no but like talking they're all
like endless
stupid they're all like huge what
honestly what are you talking about like
what was the game where you can either
play the levels or you can actually like
just roam around and do stuff
what's that called like
i don't know there's a thousand of those
what are you even talking about can you
get like an elder scrolls yes you can
beat those games yes idiot
well what are you talking about what do
you mean can you
lol rj what are you smoking oh my
goodness
so
miss doesn't know what a trackpad is
that's on his laptop by the way do games
even end anymore are they just like
endless
yes
okay the answer is no they're not
endless all right
if you want me to talk to you like a
child i'm happy to i'm i don't want to
be talked i just want to i just opened
anything
great crusaders like oh my god
oh my god let's all have a mega sum in a
crew queen bed i like you said mega some
but then you don't want to do a king bed
you just want to have it in the queen
let's have a mega sum in my single bunk
that sounds awful
gut shot cold man even lenny from mice
and men didn't deserve that wow read by
nature
great reference
poor rj getting roasted on the stream
not poor rj deserves it
you're gonna want how do i you gotta get
something man
oh watch it though watch it oh nice the
guy's gonna punch you though on the left
careful punch it
i'm get him in the head
yeah oh now the guy's got the gun
no
how do i care about everything it's all
right i think you could probably grab
you can probably if you go
that would be awesome just like his arm
yeah
just punching dude i'm trying just
making a deep philosophical statement
does that mean that never really ends
thank you it's like end of watchmen i
was nothing ends
oh wow i missed and i'm his style
although you know what diamonds just
stopped just so we can admire your
terrible shooting
just throw the gun at him
but what if he catches it and then he
won't they never catch it
you kind of did a little hop there
that's kind of cool i don't know how i
hopped though i'm gonna be honest maybe
grab a bottle or something where's the
gun play hotline miami i know joe the
gamer we should wait where is that is it
possible to win only using punches juan
asks and the gun's gone you throw it at
so many breaks you probably i bet you
probably could that would actually be
kind of fun it's like when people play
grand theft auto killing right now no
dude you're not yeah
yeah you couldn't get past this level
with a gun let's try with punches
there's a guy around the corner oh yeah
we've been here
i'm getting hanging oh somebody made a
super hot style version of pong it says
tour
jacob those things rj you're bad
yeah i know yeah exactly
uh bearski at the end versky wonders
what this would look like in real time
at the end of every level it shows you
in real time what it looks like
by the way you guys you know we love
listening to your input uh if you have
suggestions for clueless gamer or future
monday monday melees or stream cocos oh
are you kidding me
please let us know in the chat
oh that's
you're oh dude neo
you're the one bro
you're the one
oh
that was awesome you're just like
joking all right here we go we're going
to beat this level ready
bottle
boom done
thing to the head ready
if you put the thumb on the trackpad you
can tilt your controller to aim
whoa
really
oh yeah look at that whoa
thanks for telling me
mr smarty video game guy
oh nice that was awesome
now can i whip my thing at this dude
you can whip it
right in the weiner yeah dead oh
that sucks for you
then this mofo
just sneak him around the corner
hi i see you
let's get him in the dick
oh yeah
oh
that's depressing
dick shield he's got a dick shield
hashtag dick shield who are those tvs
we can play this game on it
it'll be super meta
i'll take that oh thank you very much
boom boom boom
solly world right in the weiner are you
five no what do you call it i call it a
wiener
oh oh oh oh i see you clown oh wait is
somebody like appearing behind me yeah
can you throw a tv
oh two dudes can i throw a tv i don't
know that's a good question grab one no
one's behind me there's a dude right
there just wait all right
i'd like to get past this little
you oh look at that shot down there yeah
in the knees [ __ ]
hi
so dude behind me
do a quick spin oh
whoa they're down oh and up
get him
oh
oh
i was waiting to reload i should have
thrown my gun at him
i screwed up at the end there does this
do anything that jumps i think oh maybe
that's why i keep accidentally yeah yeah
i've got a dick shield that says solid
snake on the front
i don't understand steam left and right
you rotate the controller not tilted oh
you rotate it alright fair enough
pretty hello kitty island adventure said
feet smeller ooh for a clueless gamer
that'd be fun get him in the head get
him in the head get him in the head get
him in there shoot did he get him in the
head no that guy doesn't have a gun he
has a thing get him in the head get his
guy this guy yeah the head bro dead he's
not dead he didn't blow us look
he didn't blow up man he's dead oh he is
dead sorry
there's a is there a dude behind me
aaron blair 2016 says media
oh quantum break for next clueless gamer
that sounds like a good idea is that
like quantum
nice grab that [ __ ] grab that pole
yeah i love quantum leap me too
htc vive dude we played the view it was
awesome i think you're gonna want to
kill that guy who's shooting at you oh
yeah mr smith moment
oh
[Applause]
john deere tractor simulator we did farm
simulators we didn't it was awesome
nice there's a guy in here right now
really would make your day what would
well be seeing
lol year john but seeing conan in a
battleship i don't know what you're
talking about
overwatch needs to be a clueless gamer
says like a brick we'll do our best
we'll do our best we should make a game
about george lansky's life that would be
a quick it would be like this game it's
this game yeah
they never saw it coming right here
comes this dude
super hot super huh play resident evil 2
biohazard 2.
she plays skate 3 all right
dark souls michael caine we've played a
bunch of dark souls on on uh on stream
coco
thank you for your suggestion michael
caine we actually listened to it
oh you're gonna want to go slide lap
yeah baby oh nice shots
sternum pow
dude behind you i think dude behind you
oh no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that was great
though
super hot all right here we go pretty
hard this game's hard but fun here we go
ready bottle
here we go bot stay with me bottle
head shot
pop
i throw my [ __ ] at this guy yeah boom
i snag it i'll punch him while we're at
it this guy throw my [ __ ] at this dude
oh no i come at him hard can i get him
before he shoots me yes i can thank you
what happened the dude eliz meister said
play tony hawk pro skater 2. did they
still make tony
tony hawk something with tony hawk
we're one step ahead of you thank you
for your suggestion we've actually
already done it was that the game with
tony hawk yeah we played tonight pro
skater with tony hawk and lil wayne
that's awesome be amazing
i really want to get kanye for a
clueless gamer that'd be dope what would
he play
his game
it's his uh mom getting into heaven what
oh yeah maybe not that game maybe
but maybe rosa red violet blue tony
hawk's pro skater 2.
we played tony hawk pro skater with tony
hawk was five you played one of the new
games like a brick he didn't kill a
second guy he threw the pipe back good
call
that's why i boom don't forget to kill
this dude because that's where i made my
mistake pop them in pop them in the head
this guy
throw it that guy that beat that guy up
oh jesus you better punch him nice elbow
him again hit him again hit him again
now oh maybe more time oh yeah dead
all right now that guy dropped his gun
give me that gun [ __ ]
just like it
boom
never
i love it can you play the steam
controller says shocker 45 no you can
play with an xbox controller if you hook
it up and 64.
uh no i don't i'd be awesome at this
video i think you can only do xbox 360
controller wired or keyboard mouse is
this on
conan rust oh i heard ross is a great
game
pt and clueless gamer please you only
have to find a console that has
installed we have it installed by the
way alex that's a great suggestion we
played pt
on uh twitch which is really fun
and it was super i actually got really
scared
we need to have a series of scary games
for monday melee oh that's a good call
jungle gym minion
oh dude yeah buddy that was a great hit
we've only played it a hundred times
yeah but still rocket league ah
rust is terrible says the laughing man
what is rust what is that game
this is just watching rust there's a gun
behind us
says mystic 3k i think we got it i think
it's this guy
[Music]
oh no you're good you're good
you're good you got it you got it grab
that gun nice pop him
this guy oh no seriously oh there's a
dude behind us okay here we go you know
what mystic 3k just told us there's a
gun behind us
when we start this level where
yeah where
there's no gun behind us
oh
no
this guy's really coming in
coming in coming in super hot yeah i'll
take that and there goes your head
rust is one of those infinite
beta survival games right yes
okay here's what we're going to do we're
going to take this i'm going to remember
to get this guy in the brain
throw my oh
god
always shoot him in the dick if you get
the chance
let's watch it though because it is kind
of fun oh
oh
my unmentionables
you know a game i recently just played
super hot
slenderman oh slenderman's great it's
really fun that is a fun game it's
terrifying here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna kill this dude
guy behind you yeah maybe guy behind us
already not yet yeah he's going to walk
right
oh dead
what happened he did that last time damn
it you should play the culling
you really hurt that wall says tara not
htc v even played oh ultra jesus we
played some uh we played some office
simulator it wasn't we didn't do it
online but it was awesome
play the original doom quake half-life
you know i've never played half-life we
should play that what
mm-hmm g3 last year it was fun
all right get this make this guy pay
oh
get him stick snap
uh oh
oh
oh he's aiming at it i think if you try
to throw it it's gonna oh no nice work
oh nice snatch it out i love i'll i will
that will never get old
all right homeboy behind you really
is good
final fantasy 7 i've never played it hey
jeremy piven which one is jeremy pippen
i don't know i think you're jeremy paven
who they already said i was the old dude
from orange city orange county church i
thought it was paul rudd last time i was
on here i was bradley cooper yeah well
you which is falling a couple notches
yeah
it's monday i'm looking around uh conan
has not tried vr yet strontium doc
let's try this again
tell river 85 says aaron that's not a
dick you're shooting at you're shooting
poly puds
i don't know maybe they just made me say
something dirty
never played half-life not a gamer says
jet xba
i'm just scared of the combine dude
oh whip it at him whip it at him
there you go
yeah
oh yeah now is there a guy behind you
yeah for sure
i feel it it appears that polly putt is
a type of army
you gotta kill this guy
then spin around kill the other guy did
i miss him
nope
oh god
nice
that was that was a smart move
well done dude
oh there's another guy back there oh
[ __ ] wait how do i get a gun i don't
have a gun but you know what there's a
bottle on your right or you could
maybe get behind cover yeah grab the
bottle
oh jesus oh god please beat this level
please beat this level please beat this
level here we go
don't whip it at him it's gonna hit the
wall
or maybe it won't
i knew it i knew it
oh no
can you punch him he keeps backing up
he's scared of us
just a little nice
yeah
dead
dead
so dude behind i feel like there's gonna
be a guy right behind me i feel like
that too
maybe not though ah
oh dude shoot him dead
whip it
hi uh louis cruz hello in mexico are you
missing throw the gun throw the gun
throw the gun no
no no no no no i have nothing you're
[ __ ] oh you're dead
damn it
it's only you could duck damn it
strangle it just a jump all right here
we go yeah if only you could duck in
this game all right here we go
let's get through this we can do this
oh someone from maine hi mayne
hi mayne we're in maine you love new
england yes
why'd you get rid of that because that's
not what the jonathan
germania
hello
here from the netherlands dang
now this time i'm gonna go forward
what do you mean
so that i can kill this dude
bar harbor
i've been there baja
you know what i'm saying yeah that guy
out let's go back over here
let me pop this dude right ireland
sweden popham dubai
south africa
narnia
narnia oh [ __ ] i've always wanted to go
there oh man sombra don't send me
louisiana
let me get rid of that message it's
killing me
which one that down there i don't know
this mofo has got to go
missed him
how do i get rid of that message ugh the
worst
oh no i think you missed that dude
i got that guy
i got him
it's cool how when you hit him with the
gun they lose their gun oh
it's almost like a puzzle game more than
it is
how do i get rid of that dumb message on
the thing it goes away
friend hit the steam button two times
how do i get rid of this message sombre
why did you send me a message
dude
bro out of your sombre
get out of here get out of here
there you go if you like read it yeah
maybe it'll go away
sombra
oh my god sombre
you a-hole
for your notification settings
this is the word i hate this i hate this
i hate this whole thing
filter
yeah never tell your password anyone no
[ __ ]
i don't care i don't care
i don't know how to get rid of this
message anybody anybody does anyone know
it just stays there are you serious did
you read them did he read the message i
don't know how to read it
well sombra i hope you're happy this is
the part of the game that guess who i'm
unfriending immediately where's the read
button where's the read button on this
thing message
controller what's this
web edit notification oh nice nice
oh it's an overlay
this is the worst
sombre you sombre you screwed up way to
screw the screen sombre
yeah
i got an idea press up two times check
this out
oh the screen oh there we go that's not
gonna help
i just wanna get it
it doesn't go away it doesn't go away we
don't know how to solve this so stack
them there if there are more
what's that
you should look up the sombra guy in
your friends list and read the message
oh my god
are you serious sombre
sombre you're in a faffing chat i can
read your thing on the chat sombre why
are you sending me a message on steam
literally i could see what you're saying
on the chat dude
lame-o
hombres is a hacker from russia someone
said somebody's not a hacker from russia
not all right now what do i have to do
go to the thing it's putin's guys coming
in
nothing nothing is showing up here so
this is awful
great yeah there you go well sombra
street man now everyone can see what is
a delightful message
you could have easily just said that in
the chat thank you so much i don't know
how to get rid of this by the way
they said set your status it's still not
working
is it frozen
uh
sombra bro
o'malley's moved the thing over it to me
no
well now we've just got a message from
sombra here forever
this is the funniest part so far
i'll say it's funny because now thank
you
it took us so long to do this
that now like every like even the guys
were like walking away yeah which is
really funny
you know i'm gonna get this and kill
this guy with this thing that way i have
more bullets
he's like please don't hit me in the
head
whoa
i wonder if we could shoot this dude
from over here level before the stream
ends yeah hopefully it beat the level
saw brave everyone is saying it now yeah
hopefully beat the level for the stream
ends
you know what i don't get that message
you need to send it to us directly yeah
exactly i can't see it in the chat
yes it's still there it's still there by
the way we just covered it up
here
we're gonna have to remember what are
you doing we're gonna have to restart
our computer
[Laughter]
the thing is when everyone's got a gun
let's just whip our gun at people
whoa oh we're dead
we're dead although that was close
close hopefully we'd be there now
everybody's saying it
sombra's
guys you know what hopefully we beat the
level i really am guys hopefully we beat
this level before the stream ends yeah i
just hope we beat this level sorry
that's gonna stick with me forever
someone finds a ten-year-old they'll fix
it
yeah i know exactly
oh man oh god
that dude's definitely
somehow
i blame the message i'm getting
impatient
hey hello pi 7 hi thank you for hosting
us
hello pi 7 i hope we beat this before
your stream ends sombres is the boss of
this level yeah he is
and my life currently
oh
how many votes
how many votes do you have i think it
has it has four every pistol has four
bullets i think
oh boy
oh boy
mondays right sombray
right in the dick i feel like we've
gotten far when we
go this like this way with it
you know what i'm saying somebody says
maybe sending a second message will make
it go no
don't you dare sombra
didn't miss this though
oh that guy came in hot
super hot
okay we're gonna kill this i think we're
gonna shoot this dude
and then i'm gonna whip
my gun at that guy hopefully we uh beat
this level for the stream okay we got it
you know what beth i hadn't thought of
that
headache
ah headache
oh this guy's got you oh does he he's
got our number
what
did you block the bullet i think i threw
my gun at it at the bullet at the ball
oh you can do that
what game is this oh
hopefully we beat the level before the
stream ends shout out to sombre shout
out to sombra oh let's watch this oh
boom
watch it watch it watch it pow
take that guy out take that guy out whip
it at him dude take that guy throw the
gun
cool the thing cue the thing
do the thing
throw the gun do the thing boom dead
awesome incredible
this game
oh wait a second
we're getting hacked
it's ombre
it's sombre sabre is like when will you
learn whoa what what did it say dance
can you shoot these guys
oh we're so screwed we have nothing need
a gun need a gun
what
whoa this feels like an unfair
thing doesn't seem
super fair where are the gunshots coming
from
good thing they're not all shooting at
the same time
die doc you know what i feel like we're
like an experiment
we keep jumping into like this
experimental guy
at different points
is there a situation where this
maybe they'll shoot at the door
good luck with this
yeah i know how this works hopefully we
beat this level for the stream we're in
the system now you're in trouble do you
like cheese fish in a barrel sombre is
legend
wait something happened
you don't belong here it's a good dog
whoa there's a dog said die dog and then
good dog let's punch this guy in the
face
good job
yeah grab the dog look at it grab the
dog
sombre
get out of here we can't see it because
well done
somebody knows how to play the knows how
the game is played
oh shhh
sombre oh dude punch him up bro oh punch
this guy
just working through a bunch of issues
issue working
oh yeah
what is that that's a sword whoa yeah
by the way this sword takes less time to
kill people oh nice like when you slice
them you can do like two slices
you think there's somebody behind me
maybe take a look
i like how the rectangle by the way
switches to a slice
oh that's cool that's cool ah can i
slice bullets like jedi
no um
you can also throw your sword like a
thing oh that'd be so sweet if there
were like lightsabers in this game that
would be dope i'm sure someone's made a
mod
oh you whipped it huh
oh in the heck damn son
my man
not close enough
you're just gonna need to beat this guy
up i think
oh
[ __ ]
you got him
watch the guy on the right watch the guy
on the right
nice nice nice
you can slice bullets oh you can slice
bullets while i'm dumb
ah
you got it
i just throw my gun at that guy yeah
yeah
yeah watch your six bro how
i'm coming back coming up the back this
up maybe it's black oh yeah whip the
sculpture at him how about a little art
you cretins
oh jesus these guys are rough you can
hide in the thing by the way probably oh
you need to oh i didn't mean to do it i
slipped that's crazy
slip or die
i wasn't paying attention what did you
do here i killed that guy
got the dog threw it at the next dude
sorry ben
then i beat all these guys up and then
got the sword
none of them have guns so you can go
quick
chop them up
whoa
they look cool inside
what if i hide back here i just let them
come close
rj is getting better they say thank you
very much
rj has gotten pretty good at this game
pretty good i missed him pretty good not
good yet but pretty good pretty good
what the [ __ ] man oh the dog is only a
sculpture thank god
no it's a dog no it's what they did the
chad told me taxidermy dog must be true
that we're throwing
i got shot oh man i tried too long to
cut him up you can cut bullets in half
of the sword captain lester says so i
should just probably keep the sword
yeah
that's a good good plan maybe
rj get good
sub to me sub to me for more stream
crashing says sombra
sombra sombra just totally
you're gonna make a make a
living off of crashing streams
it's fry's dog it doesn't look like
fries dog from future island
lefty lou vg hopefully we beat this
level before the stream ends
oh show this guy what's up hopefully we
beat this level i haven't played the
first hotline miami show the gamer
played what i haven't played the first
uh outline
thomas quigley hitler could beat this
level before the game before the stream
ends he couldn't because he's dead
oh [ __ ] should i keep this thing hooray
says sombre
yeah see if you can cut a bullet in half
see what happens
i'm scared to try
i think it needs to be
nope let's go again go again
go get kudos for kudos for trying oh
team coco boys this is zealous 89.
play a real game says iron mike gate
what do you mean this is a real game
this is a real game
i've come to mc complainer huge fan of
y'all especially coolest gamer those
crack me up you see our most recent
close game with seth rogen zac efron and
a bunch of uh dicks uh
teamcoco.com skimmer
i must say
about 45 minutes ago when i started
didn't like this game now i like it it's
dope it's really cool it's so satisfying
punching someone isn't it it's really
good
yeah it's dope i don't see yeah here we
go here we go all right here we go game
time set up
you're trying to
oh i didn't mean to do that
oh
nice moves bro
oh
you had it you had it
all right here's an idea watch this
let's see whip it this guy
take that
wait for the bullet to get closer then
slice it
all right
i think i'm gonna stay
i don't know about slicing bullets i'm
scared try
i feel like you got to get like directly
yeah right
i'm just going to try to slice this dude
slice him
oh you can stay pretty far back that's
sweet
try to slice the bullet
whoa
the sword is oh god killed by that
i think you know what i think you got to
do is like
the guy the third guy i think you gotta
throw something at because otherwise you
can't dodge out of it
look behind you
oh yeah behind me
even cooler with realistic animated
enemies and gore i agree and you feel
like i i hope that they use this
mechanic in like another game that's
more crazy because that would be dope
because i really like this mechanic it's
really fun oh slice the weapon out of
his hand
what's the team coco steam account we
don't have one it's just me it's just
blair aaron blair
sombra did 911 says thomas man
uh-oh sombre
so when they kind of go to that weird
flashy thing that's when you can hit him
oh dude nice
shoot that dude and then look behind you
i think there's a guy behind you too
you got him
well done no i think there's a gun
you're six
i heard he comes maybe that bullet will
get him yeah they can't shoot each other
by the way
is this a little skeptical right here
yeah it's a little elko
that's good yeah man this is
somebody's five minutes of fame
oh is that message still there
i honestly don't know we're gonna need
to get a new computer not even restart
we're just gonna need to buy i think
this tv we need to get a new tv
oh [ __ ] this is gonna be gnarly this is
gonna be gnarly
i duck no
careful you're [ __ ]
all right
all right
punch the guy right this game is fun but
hard
punch the guy get the dog right
throw the dog throw the dog
punch the guy punch all the dudes
do it quick
if they punch you once do you die or can
you okay
yeah there's no like life in this game
okay get the sword
move it up
wait for the guys to come around the
corner now how did you do this we sliced
the sword
then dodge bullet from this guy and kill
him
yeah yeah yeah oh good idea
oh no don't miss go you got him
now you need that gun quick
i bet if i just aim yeah
yeah
watch your six
good
now kill that guy
throw it at him can i do a new gun no
because i think what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna move back
i'm gonna try to move back
click
what i'm gonna try to do is move
backwards
so these guys who are shooting at me i
have a little more room to screw around
with oh is that a sword still yeah oh
you get that for sure
can i move
uh
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying i was
trying to get like in an alcove area
yeah but i think you need some braille
not zombies change this dude that's so
meta you've changed your profile pic
this is how listen this is how we
interact with our fans okay what's
happening
you are now a part of today's stream
coco stream
you know what i'm saying we like to shed
spotlights on our fans and this is how
we do it by them sending us messages by
mistake and us mocking them for the
entire hour
sabre is changing his icon
to communicate with us in the only way
he knows how it's like an alien it's
like an alien communicating with humans
nice job
oh that looked crazy
we got to do some peekaboo shooting says
mother bunker okay we're gonna take you
up on that advice
it's gonna hit the wall no oh nice
that's a good throw
but you missed totally missed
oh yeah
great move
great move
oh
[ __ ] oh he hit me [ __ ] damn it
i could beat this guy using my feet yes
you probably could and that's gross
don't touch my controller with your feet
wait you kiss your mother with those
feet i don't know what that means
hmm
i played this game to like four in the
morning one night and i felt crazy
here's an idea let's let these guys come
to us and that way when the assault guys
come over we're way closer
yeah don't you need more weapons
because then they're going to be really
close to you
oh you mean this i'm saying
here i thought you were later in the
level yeah good idea
i'm right into the wall great idea
that x-men days of future past
quicksilver scene that's this game
except that scene was better
i don't know dg diggs you got to play
this game it's pretty fun all right
well if you could click the sticks i
wouldn't touch it how much is super hot
i don't know bryson ran it's not that
expensive 10 bucks
aaron oh my god the language do you make
out with your mother with that mouth
shaking my head uh no i don't make out
with my mom that's gross
what do you think i learned those words
by the way
oh hopefully you beat this level before
them oh before the month ends wheezing
back
all right i'm gonna do ah you killed the
dog oh
febreze from sombreez
hey maybe it's sombrez maybe i'm not
saying it correct someone says it's
25 bucks 25 bucks worth it though by the
way
all right are you hanging out waiting
for the guy to come to you yeah i just
did that for these two dudes yeah i
think that's a cup that's what you want
leg
yeah pop him in the leg kneecap him oh
son watch your six
and grab that gun though or you can
throw the one gun at him
don't i just get this one so i get a new
one all right here we go should i wait
him wait him out i don't you could
you're like
hopefully we beat this level before the
stream ends
god
zombie says can i gift you a game on
steam just don't do it now bro
if another thing comes up i'm to lose my
mind
toriyam that was bad
correct
i will admit i'm getting better at this
game
you are all right here we go i will
admit that that
what you are great at it thank you
okay i'm backing it up
i'm killing this dude
did you watch the red sox playing
yankees last night i didn't watch
yesterday's but i watched all of
saturdays and all of sweet fridays it
was great sweet saturday
it was eight nothing
they were so bad they made a bunch of
errors
oh it's coming for your dick
just
uh how much i enjoyed that
all right don't be in dick sombre follow
your dreams
i don't know if we'll beat this level
before the
we might not oh it tax it doesn't stack
notifications it just replaces them
we're going to we're going to beat this
level
just get punching son
yeah
look at all these pieces of dude
everywhere dude pieces oh my dude pieces
that's the name of my album pieces of
dude
all soft songs by aaron blair
here we go here we go
am i going to buy anything on the steam
sale i don't know i got to see what's on
there
yes i probably will
don't gift descent you don't need to
give us anything sombre thank you
oh
that's a long sword
it's a dope sword
ah get out of the key nice well done
grab that gun grab the gun
you got it you got it
uh oh oh there's a bullet coming at me
this is terrifying
oh no you got him you got him dude
bring the knee
all right here it comes now i don't okay
wait let's just talk let's talk strategy
i think you want to be next to an alcove
to hide in it i think i want to be quick
maybe whip the gun down with the gun
down there maybe to have them drop their
gun
oh dude that could be a great shot and
then
whip this gun
there we go pick up the sculpture yeah
oh nice you killed the one dude all
right
oh
that is that was a good stretch breaker
heartbreaker great good strategy
man damn wait no let's remember what we
did hopefully we can beat all these guys
you picked this up quick though man uh
it's fun
i could i could get addicted to this
probably
it's real this is why i don't play video
games anymore
can't smoke half a crack rock
all right you did this right yeah yeah
that mango hide in this one
yeah
and then just move around a bunch
slice the first guy it's longer than you
think
duh
it's like the first guy that's what i
always say
mike's license best motto
slice the first guy
there you go you got that guy
oh and this guy
maybe don't get rid of the sword
so you can throw it
throw that guy no it's the new guys
oh no but you need a gun so you can
throw it
you need a gun bad
maybe i could whip it though you could
whip it let's
oh they're shooting already dude i'm
gonna whip it right yeah there yeah
hurry
got him though yeah you got him stay
next to this item
oh no you gotta can you get into the
alcove
[Applause]
all we got to do i should play gmod with
your fans what's gmod bryce
what is gmod all right we got this dude
we're gonna beat this we're gonna beat
this it's 128. we're gonna beat this
hopefully we can beat this low before
the stream ends right sombre
no
yeah
yeah
yeah
next coolest gamer engineer god we
already shot one on last friday last
thursday last thursday last thursday
which i was horrifying but it was fun
and
uh that will be out hopefully
a couple weeks
oh
watch your boy there on the right ah
you got you can definitely slice that
dude
oh
boy
we got this we got this is the last try
right no no we got this we got this we
got this we got we have 20 seconds until
it's 1 30.
stop by this clock
[Music]
i would make a couple of changes to this
game if i were remaking it what would
the changes be i would make it so you
could catch items that are thrown at you
that'd be pretty cool well what items
are they throwing at us well no i mean
like i would make it so those guys throw
items
and then you could catch them and throw
them back if you were good enough oh
yeah it'd be really hard to do it like
chopping bullets apparently missed him
oh god
it did stick in a while which is cool
that's like tink
you play anything or is anything in gmod
it is the ultimate game what chase that
doesn't make any sense i don't know what
oh it's like oh it's like minecraft but
using valve's content says hello pi 7.
oh
i don't know what that means steam
please oh cells oh valves p you can
you have a real off-camera reaction when
conan hits you are you a vid video game
nerd or do you just let it happen i just
let it happen man he pays me
money to live
it'd be cool if the red guys had more
prominent wieners how do we know their
guts oh touche
oh you're [ __ ] dead because they're
so good we gotta beat this level true as
soon as we beat this level the stream's
over but it doesn't end till we do oh
god we're gonna be here all day no we
won't we're gonna beat it now we're
gonna be here we're gonna beat it now
for an hour
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully we beat this level
before
oh wait streams are in
[Music]
missed me
and now you're dead i'll take that
will you
where did that gun go
well i just noticed that statue is
upside down
i want to shoot that
dude whoa
get the gun dude
we just dodged that hail with bullets
all right let's do a little peekaboo
shall we
you're so dead oh get him get him get
him i am not dead this dude's [ __ ]
dead
you lucky
yeah
yes
super hot oh
son
look at just boom boom
good good teamwork man figured it out
that was dodge city
well we had the right idea getting into
that alcohol yeah that was a great idea
peek-a-boo whoever you know what whoever
in the chat said he said for us to do
the peek-a-boo shooting great job that's
what it was
guys thank you for your help stream coco
fans coming through in the good job
everybody great thanks rj feederman
thank you follow that rjth on twitter
and all that stuff beth marowski
thank you guys uh thank you to the
people who made super hot thank you to
sombre uh sovereign thank you uh ruining
the stream celebrate you made today's
stream thank you very much that was
awesome uh and we will see you guys next
week for another stream coco
thanks guys happy monday everybody
you